[Musique]
je vous appelle vaut un de nos clients
et vous nous sommes son gestionnaire de
patrimoine
il arrive lundi de panama et mardi ils
aimeraient bien en proposant ses
visiteurs d'après vous convenir will
creveur se prépare féminine lui c'est
damian un employé fictif d'une compagnie
tout aussi fictive optimise management
qui gère la fortune de riches clients à
partir de new york juan mata mettrait
pas si gros que ça et on a beau soleil
en réalité il n'est pas à new york
il téléphone de radio canada damian et
un de nos collaborateurs
il appelle des agences immobilières pour
planifier des visites avec des courtiers
il dit que c'est pour son client qui vit
à l'étranger et qui souhaitent acquérir
une résidence à montréal je rencontre
est qu'elle perfore là vous allez
rencontrer monsieur bernard bernard
wheaton bernard kouchner comme bernard
[Musique]
son client tonne bernard n'existe pas
non plus c'est un autre de nos
collaborateurs qui joue ce rôle vous
attend voyez comme un homme dans la
soixantaine va visiter des propriétés
avec mélissa sa jeune copine dans la
vingtaine
c'est notre troisième collaboratrice
elle jouera une étudiante à l'université
mcgill acquis tom veut acheter un condo
d'au moins un million de dollars mais ce
n'est pas le plus surprenant de
l'histoire de tom pour ça que mon argent
vient du super fier c'est que tu as de
l'argent qui restait caché au panama toi
tu dis la police a jamais réussi à
trouver l'argent mais jusque là mais moi
j'existe on sait que le blanc cheveux
c'est tout ce qui est un contrat va
ratio avec le code criminel si simple si
je commets un équilibre c'est de
l'argent
c'est du gâchis mais j'essaie d'oublier
ce projet les au cours des prochains
jours
tom magazine rats avec son argent sale
de luxueuses propriétés des condos et
des maisons de rêve
nous avons choisi cinq courtiers
immobiliers au hasard comment vont-ils
réagir
[Musique]
mardi 18 février tom emilie ça quitte
radio canada ils sont accompagnés par
notre réalisateur qui sera passée pour
un adjoint
tous portent sur eux et caméras cachées
notre scénario va se jouer sur les trois
prochains jours
[Musique]
ils n'iront pas voir des propriétés
accessible au commun des mortels
l'agent new yorkais leur a organisé des
visites dans cinq propriétés de prestige
tout plus cher les unes que les autres
ils iront dans des tours du centre ville
dans le vieux-montréal et jusque dans
les hauteurs de westmount
bonjour santé s'étonne enchanté comme ça
va bien aller faire un tour de sega mag
rincon du 27e au quai révèlent
aujourd'hui ils paient plus dans
certains appartements
la vue est à couper le souffle ailleurs
les intérieurs son fastueux l'euro et
des courtiers ne se limite pas à mousser
les charmes des propriétés ils ont aussi
l'obligation légale de dénoncer les
opérations de blanchiment d'argent et
même les tentatives d'opérations
douteuses
c'est exactement ce que tom s'apprête à
tester tous capables ce qu'il va dire
aux courtiers ne laisse aucun doute
quant à la provenance de l'argent qu'il
fait miroiter des années j'ai fait
beaucoup d'argent avec la colombie
poursuis ta g à 90 g un vrai danger ce
pêcheur journal et j'ai accumulé
beaucoup d'argent qui est placé à
l'extérieur canada bien sûr donc été
arrêté pour ça je priais 700 ans
j'ai réduit mes affaires
[Musique]
et placé à la mort obama voit ce qu'un
jeu recherche ainsi la confidentialité
une déclaration sans ambiguïté qui
laisse une courtière sur ses gardes
oui bien sûr mais je travaille comme
vendeur si vous voulez vraiment
confidentialité que peuvent aussi gérer
le coeur mais pour les quatre autres
ça ne semble pas être un obstacle bien
au contraire même si mon argent et
classique qui a bien de l'avant du super
7 heures j'arrive à long terme du pays
ça vienne de n'importe quoi on se sait
pas moins du juge
ok mais mon argent provient de mon
meilleur ami
c'est mon meilleur ami son mari c'est la
même chose de même situation
donc je suis pas là pour juger je peux
là pour culpabiliser c'est chacun paie
sa vie chacun sait donc je vous attends
moi je veux m'assurer que vaille et d'un
compliqué dumont a rien de bien de
cadeaux pour certains pas d'amendé
monsieur j'apprécie beaucoup mais
grandement faisait déjà mis à chaleur
j'aime mieux la voir nous avons montré
ces images à des experts le scénario
crédible
la force de votre scénario c'est
justement son caractère qui parfois
farfelus comme comment ces gens là ont
pu mordre et être si confortable devant
quelque chose d'aussi sans ambiguïté
sans ambiguïté saison s'est dessiné au
crayon à grosse île à la provocation
était clair et le hipster black stars
pour cette éthiciens qui enseigne aux
courtiers immobiliers
ceci devrait dénoncer un tel cas aux
autorités quand le client musique de
très fiers drogue ou un peuple et ben
ali est réglo mais disent qu'il faut le
dire aussi dublin chemin et si la
transaction avait procédé il aurait pu
faire face à des accusations criminelles
le fait d'avoir caché sur c'est passible
de prison
bonjour je m'appelle julie dufresne je
suis journaliste à radio canada pour
l'émission enquête nous préparons un
reportage sur le blanchiment d'argent
dans l'immobilier une semaine après une
autre opération
nous contactons les courtiers pour leur
demander ceci je me demandais est-ce que
vous avez personnellement été témoin de
ce genre de situation la jupe rouge pas
gros expérience j'ai pas fait une
transaction donc j'ai moi j'ai jamais vu
ça de son côté n'avait jamais eu de
clients qui vous a proposé de faire ce
type de transaction la non non des
blanchiments d'argent ou rien du genre
non non sur les cinq courtiers 4 août
affirmé ne pas avoir été témoin de
tentatives récentes de blanchiment
d'argent
nous leur révélons donc la vérité au
sujet de tous bernard j'aimerais vous
demander si vous avez rencontré des
nommés comme bernard le dernier oui je
rencontre me reçut comme bernard
d'accord je dois vous informer que tom
bernard personnage fictif que l'émission
enquête a créé au moment de notre appel
aucun courty n'avait déclaré de
tentative de transaction douteuse
confrontés à leur réaction lors de nos
visites tous se sont vivement défendu
d'avoir manqué à leurs obligations
légales
[Musique]
y a rien du tout bien que j'ai dû lui il
a dit j'ai payé mes dettes
j'ai fait tout ce que tout montant droit
j ai fait dans les années 90 on a peur
de quelque chose qui sont moins chanceux
ce registre je ne sais pas comment
répondre et immobilier j'ai le
responsabilité envers mon vendeur puis
doit flag et le monde c'est un
blanchiment d'argent mais selon moi une
fois qu'il ya une offre déposée c'est là
où j'allais lui le flaguais nous avons
également montré nos images à
l'organisme d'autoréglementation du
courtage immobilier du québec
l'oas et i q de façon générale est-ce
que ce que vous avez vu la correspondent
à des comportements que vous espérez
world de courtiers immobiliers mais
évidemment que non évidemment que c'est
extrêmement préoccupant c'est
extrêmement troublant qu'elle entendre
des situations comme celle-là mais est
ce que c'est vrai que il doit prioriser
la vente pour son vendeur sans se
préoccuper par exemple potentiel
blanchiment d'argent ou un potentiel
manquement à ses obligations légales
la réponse est simple c'est non non il
doit vraiment s assurer du respect des
de toutes ses obligations autant à
l'égard du vendeur et de l'acheteur plus
la commission white gauche puis la borda
le tracé était l'esstic 6 juin mais omet
aux trois pour s'adosser billion dollar
ça donne si j'ai bien qu'il ait 150
mille dollars de commissions je peux
peut-être avoir une morale plus
élastique
[Musique]
de retour à nos visites en caméra cachée
nous avons vu la réaction initiale des
courtiers quand notre client propose
d'acheter avec de l'argent qui provient
de la drogue
notre sulfureux personnage ne s'arrête
pas là où cinq courtiers il annonce
aussi qu'il veut cacher son identité et
que son nom n'apparaisse nulle part dans
la transaction
c'est mélissa qui signera pour acheter
la propriété au nom d'une compagnie les
états unis cela va éclater
je dois identifier le tiers s'est levé
les acheteurs parce que tous les libyens
vont voulait se cacher alors je veux
savoir qui avait cet argent le dance
faut que j'identifie tiers pour moi je
sais que maintenant des papiers
d'identité d'une europe
parfait ok ça c'est clair elle fête de
l'amour humain peut jamais vu ces
documents et bien coexister penser ça
c'est comme si on s'était jamais vu je
me demandais des pièces d'identité vous
devenir aussi suscite la semaine à fond
si vous n'êtes pas lâche pas non à mes
yeux ne pas lâcher donc mais c'est
mélanger rien de ces matières animé par
semaine les documents car c'était quoi
que ce soit pas de conduire que ce soit
mon agent c'est tout n'aura pas ok ni
maintenant ni plus tard ni jamais un or
cette manne en que madame c'est madame
qui ont aimé moi je gagne l'argent sauf
en quête souhaite pays j'espère que vous
publiez vous vous êtes bien avec le fait
que mon nom l'appareil prend zéro
problème avec ça j'ai actuellement 0
preuve il faut bien que ce soit sur le
long de quelque chose pour les
compagnies ont quand même cinq
compagnies ou médecin j'ai zéro problème
avec ça j'adore votre façon fait et si
c'était vos élèves ses courtiers
est-ce qu'ils passeraient leur cours
dont un acceptant de pau identifie le
tiers belle c'est qu'ils acceptent
d'être en contravention avec
les règlements les courtiers sont des
facilitateurs transaction les choses
pourraient pas se faire de cette façon
alors si multitude de professionnels ne
faisait pas de l'aveuglément volontaire
là je serai la compagnie occupait avec
mon agent et si les courtiers ferme les
yeux il peut être par la suite difficile
voire impossible de savoir qui se cache
derrière une transaction dans l'eiffel
qui mauvais risques dans quatre murs
exactement ça
et si l'épée pigeon bien fait écouter
les blanchisseurs fortune à vancouver à
toronto et ça commence à bord et un les
utilise et éclectique de copies qui est
d'aider printemps fort de données
probantes
on peut pas déterminer l'ampleur le rôle
exact joué par le blanchiment d'argent
dans la spéculation immobilière à
montréal
c'est certain que le blanchiment
d'argent est un facteur qui juste si la
hausse des prix à l'heure actuelle et
vous le voyez très bien
nous décidons de pousser l'exercice plus
loin nous demandons une deuxième visite
aux courtiers monsieur bernard est
intéressé par votre propriété est ce que
c'est possible ici depuis pourvoir
prenant appui sur place ce qu'on
s'attarde reda scénario comme ça c'est
que déjà refusé une deuxième rang car on
peut toujours justifié la politesse la
première rencontre par le fait que c'est
c'est pas des policiers de carrière ça
pas comment réagir et des criminels
ils ont une certaine forme de courtoisie
naturel peut-être tous acceptent de le
recevoir à nouveau tome laisse miroiter
qu'il est prêt à faire une offre d'achat
pour moi et pour vous c'est moi que je
connais je serais moi ce que je veux
c'est un contre de hushovd à chaud je
pourrais vous avec un chèque qui vient
des compagnies de série tommy par la
compagnie autorisée par le jeu sochaux
nous on va remplir le famille facon le
sport on le remplit ok puis dax est même
celle qui semblait douter accepte une
nouvelle rencontre est lent mais une
proposition d'offre d'achat qu'elle a en
partie remplie mais lorsqu'on accepte
22e racontions on arrive avec documents
pour faire une offre d'achat en
expliquant de quelle façon le nom de
notre monsieur n'apparaitra pas là je
pense que ça démontre un niveau de
confort de normalisation de ces crimes
blocs sont troublants mélissa n'est plus
présente lors de cette deuxième visite
on discute d'une offre d'achat qu'elle
doit pourtant signé si on fait ça en
forme électronique demande a même sauvé
une photocopie du permis de conduire
pile de charbon tous les courtiers
accepte d'authentifier l'identité de
mélissa à l'aide d'une simple photocopie
chaud c'est clair que c'est en cours
d'élaboration avec la loi on doit voir
les originaux des pièces à la fois une
photocopie une photocopie on peut faire
n'importe quoi avec une photocopie
par contre et même si ça peut paraître
étonnant la loi permet aux courtiers de
procéder à la transaction est de faire
la déclaration d'opérations douteuses
ensuite certains d'entre nous ont dit
que c'est ce qu'ils auraient fait c'est
la transaction avait été plus loin
à partir du moment où est-ce qu'on un
soupçon qu'on a un doute on doit le
déclarer
1 c'est la clis et c'est le partage
d'informations si on partage
d'informations alors là on agit en amont
et plus les courtiers peuvent agir comme
chien garde à ce niveau là pour empêcher
justement qu'il y ait blanchiment
d'argent
il faut se demander avec quelle
efficacité les courtiers aurait pu aider
les autorités à identifier nos
blanchisseurs après coup ils n'ont
aucune pièce d'identité pour tom et une
photocopie facilement falsifiable pour
mélissa ils ont l'obligation de faire
les vérifications d'identité
alors si ce qu'il devait faire et c'est
ce qu'ils ont pensé semble qu'il n'ait
pas fait ça au moment où est ce que les
questions leur ont été posées
[Musique]
dans la propriété la plus chère celle à
près de 7 millions un courtier senior
accompagne sa collègue moins
expérimentés c'est lui qui prend le
relais et poursuit les discussions
brossard en amérique du nord qui vous
convient j'ai essayé de 20 ans
nous on est extrêmement de nouvelles et
chaud selon les règles de l'art et 3,6
kg mais on n'est pas le jeu il ne
questionne jamais ni l'identité ni les
intentions de tom bernard nous avons
contacté ce courtier merrill était
douteux à passe en ce moment où est-ce
qu'on a un soupçon des indices que dans
un drapeau rouge qui se lève on doit le
déclarer ses seules obligations du
courtier il affirme que sa collègue ne
lui avait jamais dit que l'argent
provenait du trafic de drogue
plutôt que de mettre un terme à la
transaction vous avez accepté une
deuxième visite à laquelle vous avez
participé y avait pas l'air d'avoir
aucun problème à procéder à la
transaction plus furieux le jeu
probablement le plus honnête mais pour
l'eau assez i q cette deuxième visite
n'aurait carrément jamais dû avoir lieu
dans la mesure où heskey ils sont dans
une situation où est ce que il constate
qu il ne prend on pas remplir leurs
obligations déontologiques et bien ce
moment effectivement il devrait dénoncer
la situation puisse retirer aussi clair
que ça
bon au panama ses courtiers seront les
premiers à nous faire parvenir une
ébauche d'offre d'achat par courriel au
total nous avons reçu trois offres
d'achat devenu une réalité sociale
certains dénoncent depuis longtemps donc
oui c'est un wake up call c'est un wake
up call qui doit être pris très
sérieusement par les premiers ministres
des provinces canadiennes
il faut comprendre que le seul outil
pauvres et les lumières sur une forme de
criminalité comme le blanchiment
d'argent
c'est une commission bancaire
[Musique]
oh